hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence
[Musique]
je t'attends rejoint moins vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
bonjour michel moi c'est un beauf
dubitatif parce que j'attende j'attends
de voir parce que benjamin comme tous
les animateurs il a quand même année ego
qui est assez important comme tout le
monde comme damien bien sûr my donc un
ego encore plus grand et c'est pas
évident de se mettre dans la place d'un
chroniqueur où on est un peu à votre
service comm mah comme dans j'ai réussi
julien je parlais des grands animateurs
oui pitié ne nous obligez pas regarder
la semaine prochaine même pour le boulot
tout est vraiment et quant à christophe
beaugrand l'atout humour de l'émission
c'est comme s'il faisait que gilles
verdez l'atout sensualité d'une soirée
cote
pour moi oui par un chanteur américain
dans le grand journal je ne savais
absolument pas le nom et qui avait une
saison en plus il y avait des problèmes
du court tellement important que je me
suis alors moi vraiment être le lieu le
lundi il avait un à un escargot d'eau ou
dans la bouche plus vraiment c'était
c'était pesant mes distances lassé et
c'était vraiment pesant donc les mêmes
il m'aurait plu sort est écrit le
chanteur
je sais même pas son nom et chanter quoi
gilbert montagné
[Rires]
en classique on a envie de revoir comme
le poteau et cetera au parcours du
combattant
on a envie de les voir et les cadres et
du candidat qui est vraiment sur le
métier on s'attache aux là il ya tout y
est la stratégie d'émotion photo alors
c'est une super épreuve mais ça n'a
aucun intérêt c'est venu de rester 32 35
minutes devant devant deux personnes
debout sur un poteau vois tu as bien
deux heures sur une top 3
[Applaudissements]
macaq
osaka non mais là je sors ma mère était
absente
[Applaudissements]
alors on va les sortir